I make my videos for me because when I
wake up and I have an Oprah video and
Oprah is kind of in my ear it makes me
want to do something bigger and no
matter how great a day I have today
tomorrow morning I'm still waking up
almost starting from scratch so I need
the videos on my channel for me to help
me think bigger and push harder you know
we have 52 people on the team now and
like really who and then I look at the
list like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but if I believe that it's crazy
then how am I gonna get the 500 people
and it's just always trying to catch the
language and the thought patterns that
we tell ourselves because I think most
of it is subconscious and so whether you
can catch it in yourself or when
somebody else calls you out that you say
no 52 people it's not crazy three
whatever million subscribers we have oh
that's great and like how do we get to
35. like nobody's done if you look at
inside of thought leadership
entrepreneurship if you take garyvee and
Tony Robbins and Mel Robbins and Marie
forleo and Les Brown and whoever and you
put them all together you're still not
at 35 million subscribers so how do I
get there and it feels impossible but as
long as it feels impossible then it is
impossible
Dominique in the house here we are
so we met a bunch of years ago when I
was doing things here and then you
message me on Instagram recently to say
hey have some questions yep and then I
said why don't we meet up here again and
do something so yeah here we are it's
good to see you again you too and I
actually I want to give you the two
minute
four story that you wouldn't have heard
so I'm a big person that's a believer in
like see what you want manifest it and
put the energy in and so
um maybe about eight years ago I started
doing a lot of visualization just to
really work on reprogramming and
attracting the right things and so I
would imagine a table with individuals
that I wanted to be my coaches and
mentors Les Brown was one of them
Janelle Monae was one of them I had you
as one of them and had a few other
people the reason being is when I
started a really big transition I found
your YouTube videos and I would watch
one of your YouTube videos every day to
learn about someone new and so over the
last few years I was at like an event at
a hotel Les Brown was randomly there and
walked up to me I've had Janelle Monae
walk up to me in a crowd and then I
randomly I don't know how but by
happenstance got invited to your event
here the other day so I just want to say
that one you're doing such incredible
work and it's so meaningful but two I
feel like I manifested another lovely
meet and greet so let's go it's not
random at all
young Les Brown is the greatest speaker
of all time it's a lot like he's just so
good at the greatest and so uh
I didn't know him at the time I just man
what a
what a human you know and then he had me
on his show
a year or so ago he interviewed me for
his show like this is giant full circle
why are you interviewing me I look up to
you this is this is what's happening
right now so
um no less is definitely one of the the
good guys and yeah just that was a good
full circle moment so I'm glad you're
back another full Soca moment for you
here too
so I mean what's on your mind you
messaged me about asking questions let's
let's dive in what do we got yeah so I
want to start with asking you about
um how you are meaningfully engaging
such a large audience online there are a
lot of people that have followers and
that have communities but you've managed
to really build a solid foundation a
solid following and to consistently keep
people engaged above and beyond just
putting out videos and so I was
wondering if you can just talk a bit
about how you are like connecting with
your followers on a level
um that is adding value to them but is
allowing them to continue to consume
your content one you have to love it
like I love
connecting with the community
so there's a lot of people who who don't
love it and you don't have to do it
right so I remember it was in New York I
was meeting a really big name author you
know New York Times Brazil Etc and
I was in town to say hey let's go grab
breakfast so we grab breakfast together
and he said well what are you doing for
the rest of the day it's like I'm gonna
have lunch with another fan who said he
like became a millionaire after watching
my content and then we're going to do an
afternoon meet up at a Starbucks with
you know my fans in New York and we're
just going to chill at a Starbucks and
ask questions I don't care about seeing
New York I just care about meeting the
people and he said that sounds
exhausting like oh what are you gonna do
it's like I'm gonna go back to my room
and write and he's had tons of success
as a writer right so it's not that one
way is better than the other it's just
that I I love doing it
and so it's tapping into like if that's
where you get your energy from of the
audience that you have and people
listening to you watching you Etc then
that's where the thing needs to be
birthed not from uh this is a good
strategy so I guess I should do it right
so inside of that
I do things like that where I do meetups
in cities when I travel even here
inviting you back it's like you message
me it's like hey what are you doing on
Tuesday you want to come by and do
something you know for Content too and
every day I'll do Instagram questions if
you see my stories I always put a
question and then at the end of the
night my evening routine no matter how
tired I am I'm still like responding to
questions I'll do like 10 questions and
you're responding yourself yeah it's me
like when I'm helping people I try to do
it with the scalability to it as well
okay so
you know the people who are here today
that I'm helping they're helping but
it's also content so other people can
learn from it hopefully in in your story
right when I'm doing Instagram q a
it's on my story so people can leave a
question I'll answer it for everybody
okay right
um I still do a lot of one-on-ones in
the DMS as well but that there's just
not enough time in the day to hit
everyone even the questions that come in
every day I don't have time yeah to do
everybody but it's more of a heart thing
where it's like I need that as part of
my nightly routine to stay connected to
the work
because otherwise it becomes why am I
doing this stuff you know the numbers
start to blur or not mean much right you
know you had a million or two million or
whatever it's like okay
I don't know what that means but
somebody's saying your video changed my
life you saying you know I watched your
videos for eight years every day to
learn from somebody new
that that's why I do what I do you know
like you've ever told me that no okay
yeah I haven't I've seen you before
right but this is the thing it's like we
when people ask me like how did you keep
going because I post on on the website
every year the year over year growth and
year one I had like 25 subscribers and
by year five I only had 2 000
subscribers it wasn't like this
overnight success how did you keep going
I just always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't that of 50
people watched your video that's 50
people right right that's pretty cool
like 50 people watch your video and I
would just assume that for one of those
for one of those 50 people who hear your
song or whatever that that's a
life-changing thing for them
not all 50 but for like one person
that's a life-changing thing so I just
assume that there's lots of people like
you who are watching my videos that it's
a part of their daily routine even if
they never tell me because eight years
later they come and tell me right yeah
so we assume that we don't matter and
we're not enough and like we're not
reaching the people and that we should
stop but
somebody is watching your stuff and for
them it's making a meaningful difference
so that's just what I feel it's a hard
strategy to give somebody because it's a
heart strategy yeah so the execution of
it of what we do changes you know if
it's the meetups or it's the IG stories
or the IG lives or meetups like this
but it stems from I need to feel
connected to who I'm
serving or helping
and in doing that then it makes me want
to show up more because if you're just
making videos in your office or you're
just recording a song in the studio and
you can't connect to like who it's going
to actually help at least for me it's
not as powerful
I'm really curious
um
so I'm a I'm a big reader
um and I the um the big leap is one of
my favorite books and the author talks a
lot about the upper limit and so I know
that there are a lot of creators that
you know they hit a glass ceiling uh
maybe they're looking to hit a million
subscribers and they're stuck around 20
000 or 50 000 but there's also that
layer about the upper limit and it's the
limit in which we're the most
comfortable operating before it gets
uncomfortable so I'm just curious as to
if you had an upper limit in your
journey like I I didn't know that you
were at you know 2 000 followers for
five years obviously that sounds like a
very normal thing but I'm sure that when
people see you online they're like oh
Evan Evan's here like it there might be
an element of your follower and
subscription in which they might be like
oh this isn't relatable to me because I
only have a thousand followers so I'm
just curious about if you had an upper
limit in your journey to starting your
YouTube channel and getting it to where
you were you are now in which you were
like oh surpassing this is going to be
really really hard for me mentally and
and if you can think of that moment what
you did in order to kind of get yourself
to the point where you can operate
online in a space with such a large
following and show up like this and just
be like this is my day today let's go
we're going deep this is great
um what a question I I face it every day
hmm
and what I try to do is Catch it in
language
so for example
you know we have
52 people on the team now
if you ask me how many people are on my
team I'd say I don't know 10.
[Laughter]
up on the team
really who and then I look at the list
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah because I'm
not in all the stuff and and I just
forget
and then the next thought was 52 people
that's crazy
but if I believe that it's crazy
then how am I gonna get the 500 people
and it's just always trying to catch
the language and the thought patterns
that we tell ourselves because I think
most of it is subconscious
and so whether you can catch it in
yourself or when somebody else calls you
out that you say no 52 people that's not
crazy Evan you you could be maybe not
should be but you could have 500 people
three whatever million subscribers we
have cool that's great and like how do
we get the 35 million
what does that look like nobody's done
it this is where all of the well nobody
like nobody's done if you look at inside
of thought leadership entrepreneurship
if you take garyvee and Tony Robbins and
Mel Robbins and Marie forleo and Les
Brown and whoever and you put them all
together you're still not at 35 million
subscribers
so how do I get there
and it feels impossible
but as long as it feels impossible then
it is impossible okay so it's trying to
catch it on the regular where
when I numbers have never really meant a
ton to me which which might even be a
downside I'm not necessarily advocating
for it so we hit a million subscribers
like oh we hit a million subscribers
but it's like okay what are you doing
tomorrow I'm gonna go back and make
videos
and when we hit two and we hit three I
didn't even want to celebrate you know
like my wife's like what are you going
to celebrate I don't know nothing you're
gonna make videos
we ended up doing a live stream or
whatever for my audience because they
were like you're about to cross too like
so we did something for them but for me
it's more it's the actual
the work it's the day-to-day it's it's
the marriage not the wedding right
and so I've never been attached to
hitting
numeric Milestones maybe I could lean in
more on those if I cared more enough
about 35 and having if I really had my
identity tied up and hitting 35 million
subscribers I'd probably get there
faster I'd probably serve more people so
maybe I could use a little more of that
yeah um but I think most of those that
glass ceiling is
is constant is it's in all of our Lives
it's in our subconscious and that's why
I mean I think the world's biggest
problems people don't believe in
themselves
because there is no box where it's like
doing this but like there's nothing
there that's invisible there's nothing
it's like you can just walk no I can't
right you walk it's like the dog that's
tied to the leash and you've seen this
like you tie a dog to a leash that's
tied to a tree yeah and it's used and
then you take the dog off the leash and
it just stays by the tree and it won't
go it's the same with elephants yeah
yeah they just stay there and the
Elephant could like rip it out it's an
elephant but it's it still thinks it's
tight that's all of us every day and so
why why I do what I do is I hope that a
video that I make whether it's like this
story with you or a Les Brown interview
or whatever that's like that's the
moment that somebody watches it and
realizes oh there's no
I could just walk there's no door I'm
not tied to anything
it's hard to catch it's like a daily
thing that you have to catch and I guess
you're surrounding yourself obviously
with the right people to help you with
catching it I could do a better job yeah
you know I'm I'm introverted and shy and
like don't don't even uh I'm not calling
people up every morning I'm not saying
hey Dominic how you doing you know
messaging Danny and say like I'm not
reaching out I could you know I know
enough people that I could reach out
more and maybe that should be something
I do I get it mostly from the
environment so it's videos like I make
my videos for me because when I wake up
and I have an Oprah video and Oprah is
kind of in my ear yeah it makes me want
to do something bigger
and no matter how great a day I have
today tomorrow morning I'm still waking
up and almost starting from scratch so I
need the videos on my channel for me
okay to help me think bigger and push
harder I feel like that's so important
because
um one of the messages that are
constantly pushed and being an artist
and someone who and is also like in the
influencer space now it's constantly
like create content for your audience
and it should be about that but I I
think I'm receiving that if you're also
creating authentic videos that start
with you and start with something that
you really want to share and speak about
that that naturally will resonate and
obviously there's strategy involved but
your concept of creation always starts
from like I'm creating these videos for
myself
obviously with some goal of serving
other people but it really starts with
me I guess at the core of it yeah it's
like what do you want to share
you know and and great art makes people
feel yeah whether it's a song whether
it's clothing whether it's a video great
art makes people feel and so what do you
want people to feel
and sometimes it's happy and positive
and you're so grateful and life is
amazing and sometimes life sucks and
and you're just looking for a way to
numb the pain for a little bit and a
great song can do that or a great video
can do that to help somebody feel not
alone
and so I think for artists for for you
know musical artists is a lot does a
tendency always be perfect and always
have it look fancy and I always have the
the perfect hair and makeup and dress
and whatever right which is great like
go high-end and like bring people in
behind the scenes it's almost you don't
even need the middle content it's just
super premium Elite photo shoot or like
here I am in my bedroom getting ready in
the morning this is me yeah here's
what's on my mind yeah here's what I'm
thinking about and a good a good tip is
anytime you have a heightened emotion
film something or create some kind of
piece of content or like whatever your
creation is if it's if it's a line of a
song or if it's direct to camera video
or you're going to write something out
when you're feeling heightened emotion
that's the time to create negative or
positive
okay if you're leaving here and you're
feeling grateful or happy or whatever
like turn that into something so that
you're sharing it with
the world and the world is people who
are following you right you're putting
out you're like extending the happiness
to others so it's not just being kind of
trapped inside you
and if you're feeling negative or sad or
you know just coming to see evidence was
just a waste of time I hate that guy
whatever that guy yeah that guy you lean
in on that too like you don't have to
call anybody out but you can lean in on
how you're feeling negative and even
like it becomes a form of therapy almost
as soon as you start sharing a message
about how things are negative watch
yourself turn it around and Lead back to
a position of Hope and so whenever
you're hiding emotion you create because
in your art you'll make other people
feel too so a question from Matt yeah
I'm getting into a new like chapter of
vlogging again and really zoning in on
YouTube and Tick Tock and Instagram and
just building uh content that's outside
of just music and I feel like I'm really
trying to get a sense of how the
platforms really operate and so Tick
Tock I'm good with Instagram I'm good
with YouTube is the platform that's a
little bit daunting because a lot of
people say that you know YouTube's at a
point where if you didn't start you know
10 years ago or five years ago it's
really hard to grow on organically so I
was just wondering if you can share any
like tangible tips for strategy in
growing on YouTube so for a Creator
that's under a thousand subscribers
they're wanting to maybe put out
lifestyle content of behind the scenes
on their life as well as in my
particular circumstance I'm getting
ready to roll out music videos and all
of those all of those things but I'm
just feeling like the amount of money
that you have to pour into ads is so
much and how are people growing
organically on this platform and for
anyone starting out like what is
something that they can take in regard
to I have this great content I have
these videos how do I start to grow my
following and to do it in an efficient
way
authentic storytelling so are you making
music videos for your album
um yeah so we have the music video shot
already but I'm doing a new series on
moving from healing to transformation so
I'm redoing my entire home and
documenting that
um doing like new types of workouts kind
of just documenting the behind the
scenes in my self-love journey and
welcoming my fans into that and honestly
I've had the content and I'm just like
how do I put this out so that it's not
just put online and it has like 131
views but it slowly grows because I just
don't understand YouTube as a platform
yeah so where do you struggle with
self-love well my self-love game has
really elevated
I don't really know if I struggle with
self-love anymore I think more so
it's making sure that I'm committing to
giving myself enough of it and not
prioritizing work over it
so I would say I've put a lot of time
into creating a schedule and being like
you need to do these things all the time
but maybe it's on the days where for
example I have a 17-hour you know
shooting a music video on tour
and you should be eating and you should
have slept a little bit longer but you
know you have to do the work
I think that that's an area where I'm
looking to grow but my thing is it's
like okay cool you've captured this
content and you have it and then you
upload it and a lot of the time if
you're not with like a major label and
you're not pouring in a lot of money
then your videos don't often go get seen
and it's a little bit discouraging so
maybe another way to re-ask that is do
you have any tips for creators that are
starting out on the platform and are
looking to build their audience
organically oh yeah no no I'm answering
the question okay the thing is
you need to open your heart to people
so I asked you a heart question
and you shut it down and move back ahead
yeah right because you said I'm honest I
want to document my self-love Journey
that's why I'm doing my house and my
workout you said I want to document
myself love Journey so then I asked
people where do you struggle with
self-love that's a that's a heart
opening opportunity
and then you went to
well I've I've fixed a lot and I've I'm
much more and I don't really struggle
with that anymore okay cool and maybe
you don't awesome but where do you
struggle because if you're telling the
stories about 17 hour days and photo
shoots and it's like the Glam life cool
but it's not really relatable
so what are you struggling with what's
the negative voice in your mind because
you're you're you're you're gonna you're
part Fierce badass gonna show up and
crush and want to change the world right
that's in you and then you're also
insecure and self-doubt and like is this
even worth it and when is it gonna
happen for me and like all of those
emotions too and all of us are yeah but
that's the heart stuff that if you can
figure out how to dive into that stuff
on a video people will then start to
love you and feel connected to you and
you're still badass Fierce chasing down
your goals they're showing all
if you're writing songs with your head
and not your heart's not going to win
if you go into the studio think okay
what is a hit song going to be and let
me just copy whoever and this is a track
versus no I have something to say this
is what's on my heart like those will be
the better songs vulnerability yeah
yeah and so if you're already doing that
in your art now it's bringing that to
just a new form of Art
and what you want is people to actually
join you the language you use is great
I'm on my journey of self-love and if
you want to swap that up for something
else cool but you take people on the
journey then they want to join with you
on the journey but you have to let them
in
not just kind of watching from the
outside yeah I think it can be scary to
like let people into the Raw
but you can even lead with that
I'm scared to let people in
yeah why are you scared the other people
in
because we operate in an industry where
um
there actually is a fine line between
vulnerability and
um
getting the job done
but go back into your heart you're like
now getting out no but that that's why
because it's like
so what happens you're afraid that if
you share too much what happens
you won't get signed
fans will won't buy your albums but
I'm sure
but that's the work right like if you
are on the you know you're on your way
home or whatever and like something hit
like here's why then that's the video to
film
um
yeah that's where people will then
connect with your heart on
and then they want to go support the
work because they see themselves in you
like I feel like that too
I feel like that always
and yet she's off going and still doing
this stuff so if she can do it maybe I
can too
versus if you're just making videos
about my 17 hour days oh my God so
stressful then over it's all right
it doesn't connect yeah
so we need to dig under the surface a
little bit yeah I mean it's it doesn't
have to be in you know in front of the
cameras here but like that's that's the
work what's so great I mean you already
do this because you're taking you're
making music
and when you
a lot of you have a hard time taking an
emotion and expressing it you feel it
but you can't explain why
so I feel scared to do this thing and
and put myself out there I share my
story but I can't articulate why like
people have a really hard time with that
muscle you feel the emotion but you
can't explain it yeah when you're
writing songs you're taking emotions and
translated into words so you're already
ahead of the game you've heard that most
people who struggle with vocalizing
anything
so now it's just developing that habit
that when when you can catch something
or in a positive way too it's not only
the negative and all the insecurities
and everything right yeah but it's that
healthy mix of both you have days that
you feel amazing and you have days when
you don't feel so amazing and do you
like I'm curious do you document that
like and your stories and stuff like do
you usually share your day-to-day of any
of the like the challenges that you're
having with your team or the challenges
that you're having on day to day with
like your dog who's just not showing up
the way it should yeah yeah as long as
I'm not throwing somebody else under the
bus okay
like I'm not throwing my wife into the
bus I'm not gonna throw my parents under
the bus I'm not going to throw Danny in
the film crew whatever under the bus
like I'll often change names change
genders because that the part doesn't
matter
or if it's so easily identifiable like
it's that person I may not share that
story but it's just about me we'll chair
whatever
if it involves somebody else then
I just I'm just careful what I put out
because I don't want to some people have
no problem with that yeah some people's
like yeah no he screwed me over screw
him you know and like his name is Danny
lau and Danny Lau sucks and here's why
right
right now some people actually love that
and that's that is actually a great way
to build a brand too yeah you know it's
a great way to build a brand okay I just
not one that I can connect with
like my first top 10 video was on Kanye
West because I wanted people to learn
from Kanye even though he does a lot of
stupid stuff you could still learn from
him uh but if I did the top 10 stupidest
thing Kanye has said or done right it
would do like 10 times better
it's just not what I want to put out to
the world okay so that's more of a
judgment call for you but it's
heightened emotion
create
okay
like it either heals you because it's a
like creating heals even if you never
even share it but if you're in a really
dark place and you write a song like the
song heals you
just the act of creating heels and when
you're in a positive place it it spreads
when you're happier great Fuller
whatever you feel like share that
because we need more positivity so it's
hitting other people
amen
yeah you know what I'm thinking about it
um
they're the the answer to yourself love
question is is connected to to a
relationship in a very public human that
I can't fully share experiences about
because they're very well known yeah but
there's ways to talk about
how you feel without even sharing
specific events okay like sometimes I
wake up and I feel like
what
staying in bed yeah like I feel this I
feel like whatever whatever you're
feeling I feel like
today is not going to matter I feel like
I feel like I don't have any creativity
in me today I've been told in the past
that I am
blank not worthy and it's a loop that
still sees in my head sometimes and
whatever else is like I'm just making
stuff up but like whatever else you're
actually feeling and uh and I need to
kick that out
it's all I'm going to get up I'm going
to do my best today and some days I wake
up and I'm on fire and ready to go and
some days I wake up and I have zero in
the tank
and I have to find the way
sorry my heart I'm like
yeah but I'm just making that up no I
know and I'm like
really
real like it's actually you yeah yeah no
but I think it's just being honest and I
think that's probably something that I
can do more of I yeah I feel like I've
maybe even talking about self-love but I
haven't been really going into the
really real and raw and and also knowing
that you can talk about the negative and
turn it around to the positive I think
I'm someone who likes to stay away from
a lot of the negative because it feels
like it's going to do the opposite for
people but that honesty and that rawness
and starting with it is going to allow
people to connect and then kind of
diverting to like but this is what I
want to do and this is what I'm going to
do and this is how I'm going to show up
or yeah the kids just don't keep them in
the negative
um
like if somebody is so if somebody is on
like it's on ground level if they're
just okay you know not happy not not
negative you could take them and start
doing amazing things right like whether
it's the Tony Robbins jumping up and
down or watching the videos like yeah
I'm ready to grow baby let's go but if
somebody's in the hole negative hate in
their life they don't want to hear that
message they can't hear
let's go change our lives change my life
have you seen where I'm at do you know
what I'm going through I can't even
right right so the key is to not talk
about growth and amazing life for those
people it's just kindness and
understanding and sharing that you have
bad days too and that you go through
things too and you help them take like
your job is just to help them get get
the ground level
because you can help people in a way
that Les Brown can't
they won't listen to It's Possible
when they're really down in the hole so
that's why he talks about
sleeping on the floor
in his office at the pranascot building
or whatever it is yeah right I'm being
told to go home that this isn't a hotel
like he shares these stories
so same thing especially if you're going
through it and you don't have to you
don't have to say the name of anybody
who's told you whatever it's it's not so
much what happened to you or who did it
it's how it made you feel
right right and lots of people are
feeling those same things and they don't
know who to turn to they could turn to
you
but you have to do the job of sharing
those things
here's a funny one okay so I I broke my
neck on tour in 2019 okay I've broken
like in two spots oh my God concussion
all this stuff uh I had to cancel one of
my tour spots because I was in the
hospital
and then the next day I got released and
I'm going to you know our our Airbnb and
um I tell my agent you know hey it's
Steve like I broke my neck I don't know
what to do on my tour and uh he's like
you broke your neck you're okay like
yeah but like I can't move I can't put I
can't put my shirt on properly like I
can't lift my hand over here and he's
like well who's helping you do it it's
like well Nina she's helped me like she
helps me go to the bathroom she helps me
no everything right and so the next week
same thing like I'm slowly getting
better but not much and I can't put my
I'm not wearing this because I can't get
my hands up to get through the sleeves
okay so we had this you know Nike
zip up thing uh I gained a whole bunch
of weight because I'm just like lying in
bed and um I'm telling Steve and then he
just starts laughing at me
[Laughter]
yeah everybody else is like how you
doing Evan you know can I help you hear
Steve like just laughing at me and he's
like you need to film that
in the film what
your whole morning routine
Steve you want me to film me like waking
up in my underwear like going to the
bathroom having Nina help carry me along
the way we had a Suburban at the time
and Nina had to like shove me into the
car because I couldn't get up the step
by myself it's like yeah yeah I film all
that that'd be great like I'm overweight
a little bit if I'm eating too much I
can't put my normal gear on all this
stuff right it's like yeah hey I just
feel my tomorrow morning I'm gonna watch
like okay so I did an Instagram live
and it was whatever okay yeah it's like
you know I mean I had underwear on so it
was fine and and did the whole routine
and took people in and it's it was
I mean for the people who joined they
was like wow there's a whole other side
but it was also for me to just release
the
release the pressure the fear like if I
can do that then I'm usually not in my
underwear and overweight and having Nina
push me to get into cars and stuff and
so I actually welcomed the
I love the off-ball questions I love the
behind the scenes the curtain pulling
like hey where did you struggle or
suffer or
um because I'm naturally a positive
optimistic hopeful
person
so it's actually a disconnect for a lot
of people like how are you always so
happy and I am very happy typically so I
was like anytime anytime there's a sad
moment it's like oh oh this is great
okay
but that's the connection Point that's
why people will love you
and that's how you start to win in the
algorithm and everything else is that
they they watch one video and it touches
their soul so they want to come back and
watch the next one so if you're doing a
house tour where like whatever the thing
is you're going to be doing next if
you're just either showing off or just
saying oh and I got this and here's and
there's no heart or story to any of the
stuff then yeah you'll stay at 100 views
of video
but take me in did you ever think you'd
buy a house did you have living beliefs
around home ownership that did somebody
in your family tell you you're never
going to make it as an artist and now
you bought this house off of like money
that you made as an artist
yeah is it only for those people and not
for me or whatever right like whatever
is actually real again I'm just making
myself up no but it's like be be honest
yeah I've never I don't think I've ever
told anyone my my story of almost
homelessness and the meaning of having a
rear first home you know yeah it's
really important no thank you I think
sometimes we need it's crazy because I'm
like on stage all the time interviewing
people and Performing and doing all
these things and it's like yeah and how
honest and real are you being with the
people that are watching your stuff
maybe it's not just that your content
isn't being put out it's like maybe you
need to be a little more honest and you
need to not only show the positive side
of things because the other side is what
really resonates a lot and so yeah and
like you're not not being honest you're
just throwing up the walls yeah
you're not being fake you're not being
somebody Who You're not pretending to be
somebody Who You're not it's a version
of you but it's not all of you because
you've walled off your heart to most
people
and so it's just dropping the walls even
even in concerts when you're performing
go talk to the audience so on stage I'm
good okay on stage I'm like
we had a sold out concert in Toronto the
other day we cry we laugh we dance that
I'm fine with I think it's it's off
stage and it's showing up and having to
like be safe when you're not in a full
artist's space because when you're on
stage it's your stage it's your audience
you can do whatever but it's like
Tick Tock and YouTube and these other
platforms it's just this really large
world of a lot of people who have a lot
of things to say and I think it's just
the fear of that judgment and really
facing it but pushing through it that
I'm working toward well you
you're always safe
and even more importantly is by you
sharing you create layers of safety for
other people watching
if you're silent then you perpetuate the
silence
if you share it's like oh wow I don't
maybe I don't have to stay stuck like
she's feeling that you're creating
safety for others and anytime you can
move into service it just gives you more
courage because now you're selfish by
not sharing all right
it's not being selfish Dominique
yeah it's like you're always in artist
mode why are we leaving artist mode
it's artist mode is exhausting
it doesn't always have to be
um
you know heightened creation but what
what does artist mode look like in
meditation
or how does an artist sleep
like it's just being really it's just
giving yourself permission to be
yourself you know
and that's not exhausting it's
exhausting to hide it
yeah it is
um
I'm curious on the days where
um so I know you've been doing a lot
more speaking and touring since things
have opened up but I'm just curious
about your routine and getting ready for
your your Keynotes and your
presentations oh uh like before I go on
stage
so I'm introverted shy I don't like
being on stage really Evan because I
would never and this is the thing about
like talented introverted people it
really takes other people a second to be
like okay
because I did not know that you were
introverted until you mentioned it which
is why I like to share it it's like just
because there's somebody out there
watching who's introverted and feels
like I can't win when I was getting
started you look at like Kevin O'Leary
or whoever is like these
fresh loud mouth type A like love the
spotlight kind of characters like that's
not me so maybe I can't win
the thing is introverts still want to
serve yeah still want to help I still
want to feel like I'm doing something
that matters I don't like being on Sage
I don't like it like I don't I don't um
it's it's the setup to talk to people in
the hallway afterwards I'll say for six
hours in the hallway just talking to
people afterwards that's my favorite but
being on stage is not something I enjoy
so I have to usually psych myself up to
to get ready to do it because I don't I
never want to do it
so what I'll do so this may not connect
because if you know slightly different
but if I'm going to Austin and this week
and the Friday I'm heading to Austin I'm
going to be speaking on stage but I'm
going for both days a lot of speakers
come in and fly out right away it's a
two-day event I'm there
for the whole thing because I love
helping I don't like just talking random
stuff you know I don't talk to people on
the subway or whatever say hey so that
weather huh George
how you doing yeah uh I could probably
do a better job of that
but if you're an entrepreneur and I can
help I want to serve that's we all want
to feel like we're making a difference
somehow today so I go for the whole
event I try to speak as soon as possible
like I want to be first if I can is the
anticipation is that no I I it's not
because of anticipation it's because I
want to then spend two days on the
hallway talking to people okay and if
they saw me speak they're more likely to
come ask questions because I'll never
come to you and say hi I'm Evan uh
you've got funky hair what do you do
right like I'll never say that but I
stand in the middle of the hallway and
then people come and ask me questions
based off of what I've said okay so I
want to speak as soon as possible so I
can spend two days in the hallway I'll
get there early and just try to
understand who's in the room and I'm um
I'll try to have a conversation or two
like I wear my gear so people usually
somebody recognizes me if I'm in a group
of entrepreneurs like somebody
recognizes me and I ask them what
they're doing so that it's a personal
connection not just
a room of 5 000 people or however when
people are showing up
um and then just before going on stage
I don't know what it's like in the music
world but for speakers everybody leaves
you alone
like the 20 minutes before you go on
stage backstage is a very kind of lonely
there's the backstage The Green Room
there's people hanging out there's but
then 20 minutes before you go up
everybody knows you're next and like
nobody talks to you which kind of makes
it worse right so I'll do two things
one I'll look I'll peek out behind the
curtain to see the audience and I'll
I'll try to find somebody that I spoke
to or just try to connect with
individual faces instead of just seeing
you know a sea of people and remind
myself that I'm I'm here to serve like
I'm not here for me I'm here to help her
I'm here to help that guy I'm here to
help
and I need to feel a heart connection
too I just make up a story like this
person you know was homeless three years
ago and now they're here and like this
is going to be a life-changing event and
I need even though it's yeah all made up
but it's just some kind of story
to get into service mode because you'll
do more to help others than I will for
myself
um and that that's the hug and then it's
also the push which is that I do
difficult things like I don't want to be
the guy who doesn't do the hard thing
I want to build the identity around I do
difficult things I break my neck I'm
going to stay on tour why because I'm
Evan Carmichael like like that's my own
self-identity that I want to cultivate
so if there's a difficult thing in front
of me I want to go off and keep doing it
and so that's the push and the the other
one was a hug and I use both okay and
depending how I'm feeling sometimes the
push resonates more in the hug and
sometimes the hug resonates more than
the push
but I use both before going on stage and
then and then I go up on stage and once
you're out you're good you know like
yeah you sing your first song you're
good you're going You're vibing you're
and then you come off like that was
amazing it's so great I think it's got
you know like why was the Sun never said
the first place and yet every time I'm
still
nervous getting up
my biggest fear of disappointing people
I don't want to disappoint people
so the idea that somebody would pay
all this money to come to this event
I don't want to let them down I don't
want to let the organizer down I don't
want to let people down
and so that would lead to mean just not
saying yes to things because I didn't
want to let people down
and in my head if it's some giant event
and there's 30 speakers or whatever
over three days and I'm one of them in
my head it's like if I blow blow it
everybody's pest when reality like it's
not it at all right like not yeah one
speaker out of 30 bombs like who cares
right but it's just it doesn't it's not
a logical thing it's an emotional thing
what's interesting though is I feel like
it's the same in the music space so I I
will say no to things that I'm like I'm
not doing a show unless I can really put
on a performance because a lot of people
just take concerts and stuff like that
and for me I'm like
I need to make sure that people
feel an element of connection on stage
but my my last album is called Queen Dom
so it's about like the journey to
generational healing and self-love and
the the shows are so um they're so
visceral like
I get people to kind of stand up and to
put some at the front of their heart
that they need to forgive and to just
sing lines back with the audience to
like bringing audience members on stage
to like learn afropop music and by the
end of it it's this huge healing
experience but for me I constantly I
have to watch that voice and another
example is I do a summit every year it's
called the Imagine Summit so it's a
second annual one that we did at Tiff uh
three three or four weeks ago and we
expanded from 25 entrepreneurs to 500.
let's go right yeah okay so this is what
everyone else was saying they were like
how did you do this this is great so I'm
on stage like interviewing like Grammy
Award winners we have like some of the
global heads at Tick Tock I've somehow
put this together I've brought all of
these people these women these amazing
groups together to talk about how we
reprogram our thinking patterns and our
processes and
I'm sitting there
and I had a moment where I switched and
was like oh this is how you reprogram
it's like you catch yourself in this
moment and you have to catch the
narrative that you're telling you put
this event together and you're telling
yourself that you shouldn't be here and
so I feel like just kind of on a win
side for me and in showing up I think
was that moment on stage where I caught
myself and I was like no you're supposed
to be here and this is what you've
prayed for and this is what you've
manifested and I kind of diverted like
have you had a moment where you've maybe
been on a lineup with a really
incredible group of people or it's an
event that you want to be booked for and
you were telling yourself a story and
you caught yourself and you were able to
kind of show up and be like all the time
yeah yeah a time every time but that
voice means go yeah when you catch it
that's that's the thing that most of the
time you don't catch it and that's why
we say stuck and stay small invisible
door but uh when you do catch it I I try
to train myself that that means go so
uh I've been a bunch I mean I was I was
at the speak at this event in Whistler
uh for this group where people pay fifty
thousand dollars whatever to be in this
group and nobody knows who the speakers
are
and then we show up and then you see the
lineup and before me is David Goggins
who's like David but like the
badass of like the century and then
after me was Peyton Manning who was like
the greatest football quarterback of all
time right arguably whatever uh and I'm
in the middle like what how am I on this
lineup with David Goggins and Peyton
Manning like could you put me in
something you know different and then
same thing is like the push I do hard
things let's go yeah I'm Evan Carmichael
this is who I want to be this is not
difficult this is just the next step and
then the hug of I'm here to help these
people because what I'm going to talk
about if I'm going to talk about growing
your brand and YouTube strategy what
does Peyton Manning know about any of
that stuff right like nothing it's true
like right he's got nothing on that I
mean I can't throw a football but
I I got value right
um I did another event whereas Brendan
burchard Dean graziosi have a
partnership where they created this
growth event and Eric Thomas and me were
the only two speakers brought in from
the outside so two days Eric was one day
I was on the second day
right right
only two people is E.T and me right and
uh it'll be great but like same thing
right it was a great event
I'm here to serve I have a different
message than Eric
right or have a different sound
different songs different connection and
and I also this is this is where I want
to play
so always
but that voice means go
and that's the thing that I'm trying to
catch that the voice of fear means go
means Now's the Time yes
and then just trust that you're guided
so the other thing that that I play with
in there is like great things flow
through me
so great ideas come to me great ideas
flow through me the fact that you came
up with the idea means it's a good idea
yeah
and then your head gets in the way so
just trust the idea
that thing that you said you're gonna do
cool go do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think a lot of a lot of the time
people are really struggling with
validating their ideas and feeling like
their ideas are worthy and um and and
even like I'm someone who's just like
you were you you were the only one given
this idea so you activate it but it's
also on the other side sometimes you
need to be reminded and I think even in
coming here today I was excited because
I was like okay
you are no longer comfortable playing in
a space where you're only posting online
because your team is asking you to do it
you want to get into the content space
of really sharing your journey and doing
it honestly and authentically but I
think that there's just been a block and
so it's like I can go on stage and I can
do these incredible concerts and then
when it comes to like get your three
tick tocks up a day
there's this voice that's like oh you
don't need to do this one today oh this
voice isn't isn't relevant you know and
so I think that kind of in taking that
I'm going to really channel that through
some of the ideas there but just in the
sake of time I think one of the
questions that would really really
support me on my journey right now is
just asking you a bit more about your
team and how you've kind of built a team
to support you in growth online and the
second one is just in regard to
consistency and really making sure that
you're constantly improving your content
but making sure that you're getting it
up I know it's such a preliminary
question but I'm working toward
consistency again on the in the like
posting on YouTube and Tick Tock in
those spaces and I was wondering if you
could kind of talk about what you have
around you supporting you and then two
yeah so it starts with a calendar at
least for me you can have an intention
but until you have it in your calendar
it doesn't happen right right you have
your concert in your calendar so you're
going to go show up like anything else
if it's in the calendar it can get done
if it's not in the calendar if you wait
till you're inspired or hope like it's
just not going to happen
or it will happen very infrequently
where I put things in my account so this
over filming content all day long here
because Tuesday is my YouTube day so
every Tuesday we're making content
and then within that framework I can be
really creative
so I'm going to make you're going to
make Tick Tock content you're going to
make sure from content you're going to
reserve Thursday afternoons every week
for short form content cool now you know
you have to do it okay Thursday
afternoon comes now it's tapping back
into the heart to say okay what what's
on my heart what do I want to share
how do I want to connect maybe you read
some of the comments on your music
videos or on your Tick Tock it's like
man
yeah that's why I do what I do or you
reflect back to your shows and the the
woman who went back and forth with you
just like you Channel or manifest the
people that you've had some contact with
and then you share the message that
comes through your heart
because that part can't be so strategic
right because I could say Dominic you
need to make a video talking about how
to get started in music business
okay here are three ways to get started
the music it's like you lost everybody
right because it's not what you want to
do yeah it's got to be something on your
heart but it's not in your calendar
and there's too much of a Perfection
around getting it right
what tags do I use and what time do I
post and what thumbnail they put up and
like okay but create like make just get
it done as a starting point then you can
then you can iterate just like when you
do a concert it took you a while to
figure out that style of having somebody
stand up maybe that was like you
probably just trusted your instinct one
time yeah and then oh my God this is
magical now every every concert you try
to make that connection yeah it's the
same thing that like you you can iterate
from your head you iterate from your
heart
and you'll win right iterating from your
it's less about what tag to use and what
time of day to post it's like post
things that actually matter
tweetable I just had an open Moment
I don't know what the sound effect is
but we're gonna go with it I'll let you
go with it it's great
you put in your calendar you dedicate
time to it and you might be sitting at
your computer for the first half hour
overwhelmed and stressed and like why
did I do this I got all these other
things I need to do this is stupid I'm
not coming with anything only 50 people
are going to watch this thing anyway why
am I spending time on this you know all
of those slots and then that's that's
your first post like I've been
procrastinating for the past half hour
yeah thinking about what the post
because I'm afraid that whatever I do is
not gonna be good enough and then you go
on your rent
talking about that or you burst into a
song like I need to clear the energy so
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to sing some hallelujah or whatever you
like whatever you need to do and then
it's like heart iterations so yes like I
love coming in and looking at data and
analytics and all that but really like
that's not how you're ultimately going
to win that's a that's a plus one to you
but nobody else is going to help you
create from your heart
but you said to give yourself permission
to do it
so I'm like don't get emotional Dominic
you can't
you know do any of that that's fine they
could fall off you know you can eat them
whatever it's great oh we got to keep
them on
um no thank you I'm I have a big
takeaway today it's like go back to your
heart space and create from there and
Trust what's coming to you and stop
second guessing yourself like yeah
always
like we're out here and we are
we are good
Dominique Evan I love it
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe see you there